um when it's an employee market i think
it sends um it sends a message to us
that
we took a lot of things for granted you
know people need jobs we can pay them
fairly we don't have to pay them better
than sort of middle you know um the the
the kinds of things that we can offer
them become uh you know secondary
because you know we have all the cards
we have all the power um and so i think
one of the things that forces us to do
is to start looking at what people get
from work the nature of work has changed
over the course of decades you know work
wasn't the place that we had our sense
of belonging people you know if you go
back to the 50s or 60s work was a place
you made a living
and you had your sense of belonging and
community from literally your community
you would whether it was much more
people were much more active at church
um we went to bowling leagues um we were
members of shriners clubs and volunteer
groups like we had strong senses of
community and and
and belonging outside of work and over
the course of the years those things
have sort of blended you know
we've seen less engagement in church
bowling leagues have
all but disappeared um and now people
are demanding things that they never
used to demand from work things like
belonging things like what am i being a
part of like that my personal purpose
has to be intertwined with with the
organization
and so i think companies can start to
really look at themselves and say do we
actually have a purpose that goes beyond
our financial uh results do we actually
have a purpose that people can feel a
part of do we have metrics that help
people see that we're making progress in
things other than what we're offering
a shareholder or what the bottom line is
producing are our incentive structures
um promoting things like teamwork is our
training going to give you skills like
how to communicate and how to listen
that will benefit you of course at work
but you'll have a better relationship
with your spouse and your kids because
of what you're learning from your work
and when we're sitting down and talking
to people and interviewing and
advertising our jobs are we saying come
work for this great job lots of
opportunity upward mobility get a great
salary or are we saying
we um we want to make you a better
version of yourself
and start looking at some of alternative
things that people used to get outside
of work that they want from work now
that are we actually building that into
our work life culture
and i say work life culture as if they
are one thing so i think i think we can
actually
it starts quite frankly by listening
which is call the people who have left
and say can you tell me not why you left
can you tell me what what you're leaving
for
um you know what are you pursuing and
then everything they say don't have an
answer don't say well we already do that
don't try and fix something just say go
on tell me more i don't understand go on
tell me more and really get a full
picture of what's going on in people's
lives and what their ambitions and
dreams are because i would i would bet
money that um
that a lot of the things that people
feel like they're lacking that they're
looking for that they're searching for
probably at least some of it we could
help them find at work but the problem
is we don't promote those things even in
our recruitment ads you know
why don't we start talking about our
vision our mission and how we help
people grow before we talk about upward
mobility salary and where you want to
work
so i think we can start looking at some
asymmetrical things that we didn't use
to look at quite frankly they've always
been there we just didn't need to look
at them